please if you're a studio executive
you're watching this do not ruin back to
the future
do not ruin back to the future by making
a female back to the future
it would be terrible think about it
deeply this is not a good idea
seek out original ideas from
original creators who have original
stories to tell
please
chris we asked you previously why 99 of
today's movies
are garbage that was a few months ago
that we asked you that question
the videos got well over 5000 comments
a lot of people had opinions on it upon
reflection is there anything you'd like
to add or clarify
that you didn't with that video
well i that i mean that could be an
ongoing podcast
why 99 of movies are garbage it's really
documenting all the mistakes that
filmmakers make
i think i think one that i've seen as a
trend
that i think i failed to mention in the
previous video
was the gender swapping of of
characters i think that um
i mean you know i i've seen how people
think that that's a well we'll just do a
female terminator
or we'll just do a female you know a
female version
of x i always think it it's better to
start with an original character
and have a and and and approach it
approach a film that way i find it kind
of pandering on
on hollywood's part to just we're just
going to do this franchise
which we already know is proven success
and we're going to gender swap
the lead i think i i think that's lazy
i think it's pandering to a certain
audience and that audience may not even
really be there
uh and i think that that fans of those
franchises
completely see through that
and it's it's um you know i mean
the latest uh that mad max movie that we
did
that that they did uh recently um
fury road he's really kind of the side
character
but what charlize theron did she created
this amazing
new character i think they kind of that
was maybe the
right way of doing that the wrong way
might have been the the you know
terminator film
dark fate um which i'm not sure who
loved that movie
um i know it didn't do too well at the
box office
i mean um sarah connor is already
um an amazing character i don't know why
you need to
you know flip things
and gender swap i think again i think
audiences see
audiences see through that um an example
we talked about this earlier was um
you know one that thankfully they'll
hopefully never do
which is back to the future there's been
rumblings
of bringing the back to the future
series and doing a reboot of back to the
future there was
a rumor years ago and i pay very little
attention to rumors
because most of them we all know are bs
but there was a strong rumor that justin
bieber was going to be
in a reboot of the back to the future
series
but that's a franchise you i don't think
you could ever
you could ever gender swap the lead
the lead like and call that lead mandy
mcfly and having some sort of
weird relationship with a younger
version of her father would be very
awkward
i mean that just doesn't work and then
there are cases where gender swapping is
irrelevant
for example the upcoming dune movie
with timothy chalamet there's a
character named dr liet kinds which i've
read the novel
obviously seen the 1984 david lynch film
the gender of that character is
absolutely irrelevant
not relevant to the character whatsoever
in in that case
um uh maybe in in some ways can kind of
add to
something when you're doing it just to
pander to an audience
audiences see through it i i really see
it i really
feel that when you are pandering um
whether it's queerbaiting or you know
gender swapping characters or race
swapping
it's lazy it's lazy
you know i'd rather see more
original characters
that are are you know maybe by
female creators black creators
where are their voices if you're simply
taking you know
creators who have done things that just
changing the gender or race i find is
lazy and that and and i i think that
audiences
they're they're they're not really in
favor of it you know
um it it seems to
not be working and i i think i think
if hollywood just leaned a little bit
into originality
a little bit more into originality
and took some risks with new creators
see that's the thing that i think people
don't understand is that
the original creators of those
characters they get money
right they get money and so
i don't understand why there's not more
of an effort
to find people who have created
original characters um that
are all across the spectrum of ethnicity
or gender and and make and make movies
with those characters
right i mean the original creators of
those properties would profit
so i think pandering is
probably a a huge mistake
and underestimated how savvy
audiences are that they see through it
so if i come in and say i want to do a
male version of heather's
or jennifer's body or uh mean girls
you know i mean hey there's mount
there's male bullying there's all sorts
of stuff
so it's john's body okay sure
that's not that's not probably gonna
work or
it's so blatant that i'm flipping it
here's the thing i've seen that story
so i've seen those stories changing the
gender is not gonna
is sort of you know make me care about
the character because the point is is
this
i you know i i identify with so many
characters that aren't
me right and i think
that you have to create something that
comes from the essence of what that
character is ripley is a character
i loved as a kid ellen ripley
played beautifully by sigourney weaver
in two and a half good movies but
but but you know i i i think that just
the
the sort of you know i think it's just
lazy to do that
but it's an opportunity for an audience
to identify with someone that isn't them
and i feel like
you have to as an audience
member be capable of seeing the world
through someone else's eyes
i i've said this before i don't know if
i've sent it in
but in another video but like
you have to as an audience member have
the ability to
identify with someone who's not you
that's how you know even the
storytelling is great
if you can take just sort of a regular
dude like me and i can identify
with a woman who's maybe not a woman
who's white
so maybe not a woman from the united
states
who's maybe a woman that's going that to
me is great storytelling
i would say another film that i
thoroughly loved
amelie french film amelie right okay
not a woman i don't speak french you
know a lot of her experience is very
different from mine
but i identified with her i was on her
journey
uh and so that to me is you know
storytelling is great
when you know vastly different people
can identify with someone that is not is
not
themselves i don't need to see me
reflected
in a film in fact i prefer not to you
know i want to see someone new and
interesting and different
and i think that what's lacking in the
storytelling
is is is making these stories universal
so the gender and ethnicity is
irrelevant
it should be irrelevant
yeah i mean just you had said earlier
about the the marty mcfly character
turning into andy mcfly and you're right
it it wouldn't work
for the especially for the one fact of
flipping it with the dad now to have a
biff character
that's female that's bullying her that
actually would be interesting
and and and then her sort of going on
this journey and playing in a band see
now you're being like a studio executive
and you're
you're pitching the female back to the
future please
please please i will say this to camera
which i know
my eye line is you but i'm going to say
to camera please if you're a studio
executive you are watching this
do not ruin back to the future do not
ruin back to the future by making a
female back to the future it would be
terrible
think about it deeply this is not a good
idea seek out
original ideas from original
creators who have original stories to
tell
please
please so i don't have to do
a third version of this video please
you